[Music]
Welcome to our sutv secrets unsealed
question and answer program I'd like to
know we're delighted that you decided to
join us today and we trust that the
questions that we attempt to answer uh
will be a blessing to your life and will
amplify your knowledge of scripture amen
I have with me uh Pastor David Salasar
uh and uh he works with us on this
program on a regular basis thank you for
being here thank you Pastor uh we want
to uh remind you that we crave you
sending us your questions uh you can
send your questions to the following uh
email address
TVM tv.org once again you'll see it on
the screen tvsm
tv.org we'd be delighted to get your
questions and uh we do the research and
then uh on uh the air we attempt to
answer these questions so I'd like to
ask Pastor salad to please have a word
of prayer for us and uh then we'll get
right into the word absolutely let's
pray Heavenly Father we are so thankful
to be able to come to you and to your
throne of grace to ask humbly to give us
a portion of your holy spirit that we
may receive the Heavenly instruction and
the discernment that you want us to have
when we open your word help us Lord to
be able to give answers that may Point
uh the individuals the friends that are
watching this program they may that they
may Point them to you and they may
receive a Blessing by studying and
reading your word we thank you for your
grace and we thank you for all that
you've done for us we pray this in
jesus' name amen
amen okay we have uh several very very
good questions that we're going to cover
in our program today and the first of
those questions uh is
this can you explain who the Saints are
in Jude 114 so why don't we just read
that uh text first and then we'll finish
reading the question yes Pastor let's
I'm going to go to the book of
Jude um which is sometimes a little bit
sneaky as is one chapter here we go
before Revelation Jude verse 14 there's
only one chapter so it would just be one
verse
here now Enoch the seven from Adam
prophesied about these men also saying
behold the Lord comes with 10,000s of
his
Saints uh the interesting thing is the
context is that
here Jesus or God is going to come in
judgment against the wicked he's coming
with 10,000 of his Saints to punish the
wicked for their wickedness according to
the context now let's finish the
question I know this person says that at
the second coming Jesus is with
thousands and thousands of
angels why in Jude are they called
Saints I always thought the people of
God are called Saints is Jude referring
to the second coming or is this a
reference to his coming after the
Thousand Years in heaven in other words
after the Millennium so what can we say
an answer to uh this question well first
of all uh this is a question that comes
into the you know it's a good question
because she's you know this lady uh
Helen is asking the question in regards
to whether or not the word Saints is
referring only to the saints that are
resurrected or the or the redeemed or
can this be the Saints in reference
to the angels and and so she has this
question about the word specifically so
briefly the word in the Greek that
that's named here the word for Saints is
a word hagios which is the same word
that can be translated as
holy and uh there's many different
verses there's actually 229 229
references throughout new testament
where that Greek word hagios is
translated as either holy for example in
Matthew 4:5 where it mentions there that
Jesus was taken by the devil to the holy
city
and showed him in the Temptation you
know the the the temple and and and then
the Temptation that came to Jesus well
that word holy city that word holy is
the word hagios also when the uh when in
Mark
1:24 we actually see that in that verse
the there is this demon possessed
individual who says I know who you are
you are the Holy One of God again that
word the same word hagios is used to
describe a holy individual in this case
Jesus and in Luke 9:26 it also mentions
that the word the same word hagos for
Holy Angels so uh this is again why this
word hagios is not exclusively only in
reference to the Saints yes is used for
Saints for example also when the the
Saints are mentioned that are
Resurrected when Jesus uh died and
resurrected and the the first fruits
were resurrected it also mentions the
word hagos there in Matthew 27:52 so it
could be used for Saints but it also can
be used for Angels it can be used for a
holy place or for the holy or for the
holy spirit for example so this is why
you know is important to know that this
word is not exclusively only for Saints
and uh that's the first thing that we
can say about this but there's also as
you Pastor B you know there's other
referen is that we're going to be able
to show that this is not exclusively or
is not speaking of the saints that are
redeemed yeah I think we need to deal
with several things first of all we need
to look at the source for Jude 14 where
it actually comes from it comes from the
Old Testament that's right and then we
have to look at uh the source or the
meaning of the expression 10,000 correct
and then we need to see if uh the word
Saints can refer to the angels and not
only to the redeemed so why don't we
first of all uh look at Deuteronomy
33:2 which is uh very very similar to
Jude 14 yes it says here in the Bible
Deuteronomy 33 verse two and he said the
Lord came from SI and Dawn on them from
seier he Shone forth from Mount Paran
and he came with 10,000 of saints from
his right hand came a fury law for them
okay so so this verse is very important
because it's talking about God coming to
reveal his law in Mount Si and it says
that he comes with 10,000 of his Saints
yes now obviously those cannot be the
redeemed at the second coming it can't
because they're coming when the law is
given on Mount Si so we begin to get the
idea that the expression 10,000 Saints
is not referring to the redeemed but it
is referring specifically to Angels
right uh now uh let's go uh and see
where the expression 10,000 uh lands I
mean what what uh is the meaning of the
expression 10,000 uh let's go to Daniel
7: 9 and 10 correct Daniel chapter 7: 9
and 10 gives us the expression there
10,000 and we're going to also look
later with Revelation 79 and 10 it says
here I watched till Thrones were put in
place and the Ancient of Days was seated
His Garment was white as snow and the
air hair of his head was like pure wool
his thr was a fury flame its Wheels a
burning fire a fury stream issued and
came forth from before him a thousand
thousands ministered to him 10,000 times
10 thousands to before him the Court was
seated and the books were opened so what
does the expression 10,000 refer to in
that passage in that passage only can be
referred to Angels there's no no doubt
about that absolutely now let's look up
also Revelation 5:1 correct Revelation
51 the same expression is used exactly
and let's see uh who it is referring to
it says there then I looked and heard
the voice of many angels around the
throne the living creatures and the
elders and the number of them was 10,000
time 10,000 and thousands of thousands
so once again here we see the 10,000
being connected to Angels not to redeem
but to the angels of heaven right so
Jude must be referring to Jesus coming
with 10,000 of his Saints means 10,000
Holy Angels correct uh which is by the
way 10,000 is uh simply around around it
means many many many absolutely uh and
then the question is are angels referred
to as holy or as Saints uh the answer is
yes Mark 8 verse 38 correct this is
another one of the verses where that
word uh hagios is translated as as for
as Angels it says there
38 you do uh Mark oh sorry 838 I was in
Mark n here we
go for whoever is ashamed of me and my
word in this adulterous and sinful
generation of him the son of man also
will be ashamed when he comes in the
glory of his father with the Holy Angels
or the saints Saints so so the angels
are also called Saints correct so Jude
14 when it speaks about uh coming with
his holy ones or with the Saints MH
10,000 Saints yes clearly in the light
of other texts from scripture it refers
to the angels he's coming with the
angels uh one more verse Matthew
24:31 uh tells us that when Jesus comes
he he doesn't come with his Saints he
comes for them amen it says there and he
will send his angels with a great sound
of trumpet and they will gather together
his elect from the four wings from one
end of Heaven to the other once again
the Lord comes with his angels he
doesn't come with the redeem you know
his his appearing of course he comes
with the angels comes with his angels
for the redeemed amen amen okay I hope
that that uh pretty much covers the
answer to the question yeah uh so let's
go to our next question and this one um
I don't know that we have enough uh
information to really answer
definitively uh what is the next
question well let's see this question
comes from from Montreal Quebec which is
a blessing to know that we're being
watched there it says the question hello
the seventh day the Sabbath existed
before creation of this life on earth
and the planets that's a that's a
question that's a question that he has
you know or yeah and did everyone rested
on the seventh day in the eternal life
where the kingdom of God or heavenly
father or is it specifically was
Sanctified and blessed for humans since
creation to have a personal relationship
and a personal connection with Yahweh
the father of all of all of us I know it
is going to be important in eternal life
as well as as is written in Isaiah 66:22
and 23 if I understand correctly as
Jesus Christ said the Sabbath was made
for men so he has a question whether or
not the Sabbath was only made for men
for us or was the
Sabbath before creation was did exist
before creation that's the question
question that we have um well uh the
Bible says that Sabbath was made for man
and not man for the Sabbath however many
of the things that God Made In This
World already existed before MH like for
example in the New Jerusalem the River
of Life there's a tree there you know
there are many things that uh that came
into existence on this Earth at creation
uh of course the big question is uh was
the Sabbath kept by the universe before
the creation of this world we know that
it's going to be kept on this Earth
after Jesus comes and after he makes a
new heavens and new earth but uh did the
universe keep the Sabbath uh in eternity
past that's a good question and and you
know and sometimes I I've had some
people ask a question similar to that in
regards to the the law you know if the
law of God is eternal and we know that
the Commandments of God are you know
specifically mention the Sabbath some
people say well you know then they must
have to be ex you know the Sabbath must
have had to be exist before but at the
same time some individuals have said
well the law of God is kind of adapted
to humanity in way so there's this
question so I think that's a you know
it's a valid question but maybe we don't
have a full answer for this you know
that's the truth I mean uh there's not a
definite answer but you Pastor Bor you
know uh have mentioned some things in
regards to this before yeah you know God
uh the purpose of the
Sabbath uh was um at the end time is to
test man to see if he will be faithful
to the Creator right to his creator it's
a sign of creation and it was throughout
the course of the history of Israel also
uh in Exodus 16 the Mana episode God
says I'm going to test you to see if you
will walk in my law um
but God can can uh give other worlds uh
different
tests like for example in the Garden of
Eden there was a test the test was a
tree right so um the Sabbath in the
fourth
Commandment
um will eventually be the test uh for
Humanity at the end of time but God can
uh test us to see if we respect the
Creator in different ways of doing it so
uh I think that the importance of the
Sabbath is a reminder of the Creator mhm
and uh the question is is that the
reminder of the Creator in eternity past
and Eternity future and I don't think
that we have a specific answer at least
I haven't been able to find a specific
answer to that question correct I that's
that's the thing I think we we could not
you know we cannot affirm something has
not been revealed and what we can know
for a fact is as he actually mentions or
or she mentions the same answer we don't
know um whether or not it's a woman or a
man but that has this question but the
the thing is we know for a fact that we
will be keeping the Sabbath in the
future in the new Heaven and new earth
and it is a sign that God gave for for
his people for those who obey and love
his word so ultimately speaking you know
whether or not it was kept in the past
whether or not it was the same day for
everybody in in eternity you know or you
know that's something that we will know
when we get there I suppose you know we
can ask those questions but this
question is not one that we can affirm
right now and I think that has revealed
enough evidence for us to know that it
is a blessing to keep the Sabbath today
it is the sign that he has set apart for
us to be Sanctified to experience that
relationship with Christ and as we
partake of that day
let's look forward to that you know that
experience and let's move in faith to
the fact that we will be keeping the
Sabbath from hence forth to the eternity
and uh God will reveal to us you know
what whether is just only for mankind
the Sabbath was made or I mean
specifically for us or it was a part of
a larger system around the universe yeah
um many questions we don't have answers
for right now the important thing is
that we get there amen that's exactly
and then we'll have all the answers
exactly uh but we do know for certain
that the Sabbath from the very beginning
uh God established for us to keep amen
and it will be kept in eternity future
right we know that but as far as before
that um we know that the law of God is
eternal but was the test concerning the
Sabbath the Sabbath itself or was it
another test that God had that has the
same purpose or the same intent that
we're going to have to wait for an
answer
yes um okay the next uh person sent
actually two questions this is Robert G
uh doesn't tell us where uh he's uh sent
the qu sending the question from uh I
want to encourage those who are watching
the program if possible please let us
know where you're sending the question
from uh we want to know uh what our
reach is we receive questions from all
over the world but uh it Delights us to
know specifically where the questions
are coming from uh okay uh this uh
person Robert sends us two questions uh
the first question is actually uh quite
simple uh it is regarding Luke 1 and
verse
46 and this is how it reads and Mary
said my soul magnifies the Lord and my
spirit re rejoices in God my savior mhm
uh and of course the question is
um you know how what do we say about
these two scriptures about the word
Spirit and the word soul that is used
here are they two different distinct
things no I I I think that that that's
well it sort of one verse actually these
are two verses 146 and 47 the first
verse
describes how
she how she is filled how she is
rejoicing in the Lord so her her heart
her
mind her the feelings and emotions in
her heart are of gratitude and and
magnifies the Lord and then she says my
spirit just is my God my savior so it's
basically an expression of the emotional
aspect that how she feels how she
rejoices how she magnifies the Lord is I
I I think that this is just a like again
like a like the same word just expressed
in a different way uh that's an
important uh important Point uh Hebrew
poetry because this is poetry right
Hebrew poetry is based on the principle
of
parallelism uh you have um synonymous
parallelism right which uh where you
have in one line is repeated in the
second line the same concept in
different way words mhm you have
antithetical parallelism where the first
line the opposite is set in the second
line mhm and you have synthetic
parallelism where the first line is
Amplified yes in the second line correct
um I think what we have here is what we
would call either a synonymous
parallelism or a synthetic parallelism
where the second line completes the
thought of the first line correct um and
that would be be my soul magnifies the
Lord and then the second part uh in the
next verse my spirit rejoices in God my
savior either completes the thought of
the first line or um or simply is
synonymous with what we find in the
first line uh so in other words I think
we have here either a synonymous
parallelism or a synthetic parallelism
where the second uh verse
is either amplifying the first verse or
completing the thought of the first
verse correct and following along along
the lines Pastor what just mentioned
just to confirm the the parallelism or
the synonymous of these two words uh the
verse there or the word there for uh
spirit or Soul rather the first verse
Soul which is an word Su in the Greek it
deals with the idea of breath or the
spirit that animates the body you know
the the and or even the idea of the of
the where the feelings with the emotions
are so there are different meanings to
this word or or the explanation of this
word uh but usually is in in L with the
expression of bread of life and then the
other word in verse 47 which is
translated as Spirit which is the word
Numa it's also can also
mean the same same concept in other
words even though it's used for the
spirit of God or or speaking of the even
the the the force that comes from God it
also deals with the vital principles by
which the body is animated and or the
rational spirit the mind and so these
are words that can represent a similar
meaning a similar idea even though
they're different they actually
represent a cinemon a parallelism rather
between one or the other they are two
words that can complement and can mean
the same thing just in a different
expression in other words they don't
have a strict closed meaning correct uh
but they can have a Nuance right in
other words Soul and Spirit can be used
interchangeably right in different texts
of the Bible to refer to it can refer
the word Soul can refer to the total
person right man became a living Soul
right or can refer to emotions and
feelings uh Etc mhm so um basically what
we have here is that she's saying my
soul magnifies the Lord and uh you know
and that leads me to rejoice in God my
savior exactly uh so anyway I trust that
this uh will be um helpful for the
person who sent the question forever
yeah uh we don't have time for another
question uh we have just a few uh
seconds left I want to thank all of you
who send your questions to us and I want
to encourage to you to keep them coming
uh we really need them in order to carry
on this program also I would like to
encourage you to continue praying for
Secrets unsealed in some TV uh that the
Lord will continue to use us for his
honor and glory and for the Salvation of
Souls and also I want to thank all of
those who contribute financially for us
to be able to function as a Ministry our
passion is to pres take present truth to
the church and to the world and with
your financial contributions that is
made much more possible God bless you
all thank you for being with us we hope
to see you next time on this our
question and answer program I'd like to
know
[Music]